they just know how much it enhances
after you nap right how much more you
can retain all right welcome down to who
is funding the research oh sure right
right yeah all that sugar industry would
say sure if the pillow industry is
telling you to take naps yeah unless
it's my pillow without by cause it's
American big pillow yeah you think the
pillow industry is really campaign like
we gotta sell more pillows what's going
on studies out there
speaking of mark marketing though I
don't know if we mentioned that that my
pillow did we mention this the my pillow
it that you know I even know the name my
pillow have you ever put your head under
my pillow no it's like a cinder block
you're like though it's an it's so
uncomfortable it's it's hilarious but
you know it's like that I'm an American
guy we made them here this episode of
history hyenas brought to you by my
pillow oh yeah we have our thing you
gotta try it's the sponsor of today it's
the little dictionary it's actually like
the example for why everything went
overseas we don't buy it you're going
like I get it same thing with Casper
mattress everyone buys a Casper it's
like oh those are good oh are they all
yeah good I also might sponsor can I
just say that guy looks like he's never
held anything in his life the most
awkward like mannequin hands like tasty
when you lie on he looks like but he's
an American kid oh yeah have you seen
those infomercials oh you've never seen
in LA it's probably different
infomercials I mean no my pillows
everywhere man yeah it's like hipster
commercials hey do you have a pillow the
past checkout my pillow no my pillows
are everywhere man yeah let me see this
guy Fox I love this guy yeah
in there I guarantee that this guy
doesn't make those pillows I guarantee
you some huge company that's like let's
find the most normal American guy who
you would read it like a bar in the
middle of Wisconsin really building yeah
I mean he's just like you doesn't even
know what he's talking you do you have
problems with your vertebrae okay then
then slap this three times lie on it on
a Tuesday and you'll figure it out by
Friday the pillows are soft okay you
call it color corded by the way colors
for pillows one of the colors is women
[Laughter]
true that's true and it's white white
women this is all [ __ ] it's
hilarious
yeah yeah that's perfect you like that
child stomach sleeper that's Alessi he
wants you child chokes on its vomit how
do you guys not see the my pillow
because you're not watching because
they're watching [ __ ] like they're not
watching TV at night like when they're
drunk eat it like we watch TV no
position there was hard to avoid for a
little while it moves every channel is
everywhere I mean he's making it up as
he's going along this one's a dwarf
pillow over here this one is for your
crotch over here when you're alone in
the middle of the night and you don't
have another
men in your bed you put it between your
legs and here we go and there's next
below this one over here is what you're
you don't have that much money you're
splitting the hotel room but your buddy
but you don't want to feel like a
homosexual she put this one between the
other guy it's a good wall it's a
straight wall he's just making it up as
his [ __ ] head now I think he dropped
out of a heart attack right now he's
still alive though I love that pillows
for almost all guys almost yeah this
guy's Jesus on his chest
when have you ever walked into a hotel
and seen a pillow and been like that
one's not my size no that's for
extra-large guys I mean yeah that was
yeah that pillow over there that's
called front desk like I'm sorry you
don't have the right size pillow for me
I'm a medium-sized guy you got
extra-large guys you gave me lady pillow
you give me a lady pillow this yeah I
mean this guy couldn't be more full of
[ __ ] but he's is that hello Jesus Christ
yeah this is straight out of central
casting now here's the thing about this
pillow you will fall asleep for three
days and rise three days later this is
the this is the save your pillow if
you're wildebeest of a woman anyway 400
pounds this pillows for you and all your
back issues now if you want to kill
someone this one's really in a [ __ ]
hold over someone's baby honest father
[Laughter]
beefcakes women is not for you true
inventions
why because it's not gonna go flat yeah
out of my skull is due they're gonna
stay what you get is what it is yeah so
don't buy up thinking it's gonna be like
a conventional pill that goes flat yeah
it's gonna be the same on day one as it
is on year you are so full of [ __ ] all
pillows go down when you put your head
on them yeah that's what it is
imagine you're born and this is your
life to be this guy oh my god imagine
like you look back at your life you're
any death Beck I was like I was that I
that's what I got I was bullshitting
about pillows as my pillow guy I was my
pillow guy I've been looking for yeah it
works exactly the same
you've got your thinnest floppy in your
yellow white he paused for a second he's
got four pillows on that table
I cannot tell the difference between any
of those pillows no like this if I went
to his demonstration I would be like
dude I don't see a difference they all
are the same pillow he could have those
could be for the same pillows and he's
saying how this one's woman pillow
this one's just hello them up and down
on the table yeah this is what my pillow
is all about it's gonna stay where you
put it and it sounds like he's actively
having a stroke yes important through
this commercial we do have the 60 60 day
money-back guarantee but you're not
going to want to remember return this
pillow if you get fitted right that's my
return adventure neck or the upright
you're not gonna like it yeah this way
fitting is so important and if you
follow what I just told you so you got
to watch that drunk instructional video
to make sure you get your bill all right
yeah that yeah look Nate bargatze did a
my pillow reveal
one down